>>> ELON MUSK TAKING TO TWITTER.
THE PLATFORM HE NOW OWNS AND
OPERATES URGING
"INDEPENDENT-MINDED VOTERS" CAST
BALLOTS FOR REPUBLICANS IN THE
MIDTERM ELECTIONS TODAY.
WHAT HE TWEETED "SHARE POWER
CURBS WORST EXCESS OF BOTH
PARTIES THEREFORE I RECOMMEND
VOTE FOR A REPUBLICAN CONGRESS
GIVEN THE PRESIDENT IS
DEMOCRATIC."
THAT IS A CONTRADICTION OF WHAT
HE TWEETED JUST A FEW MONTHS AGO
WHEN HE WROTE "FOR TWITTER TO
DESERVE PUBLIC TRUST IT MUST BE
POLITICALLY NEUTRAL, EFFECTIVELY
MEANS UPSETTING THE FAR RIGHT
AND THE FAR LEFT EQUALLY."
LET'S TALK TO PROBABLY THE ONLY
TECH JOURNALIST WHO INTERVIEWED
BOTH ELON MUSK ON HER PODCAST
AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
JOINING US.
>> THANK YOU.
>> BEYOND THE CONTRADICTION OF
ELON MUSK, CLEAR THERE, HE OWNS
THIS POWERFUL PLATFORM NOW AND
SEEN MISINFORMATION AND HATE
SPEECH JUST SINCE HE TOOK OVER.
WHAT'S THE BIG PICTURE HERE?
>> HE LIKES TO TWEETS AND SAYS
WHATEVER HE FEELS LIKE WHEN HE
TWEETS AND DOESN'T CARE ABOUT
CONTRADICTIONS.
HE DOES WHAT HE FEELS LIKE.
IF YOU READ IT, THAT'S NOT THE
WORST QUOTE YESTERDAY, ALTHOUGH,
YOU KNOW, WHAT HE BELIEVES.
HE ACTUALLY DOES BELIEVE THAT
ONE, IN BEING, BEING IN THE
MIDDLE.
THINKS OF ARE HIMSELF AS AN
INDEPENDENT.
SAYS ALWAYS VOTED DEMOCRAT,
ALONG, ALSO ALONG WITH THOSE
TWEETS AND THIS YEAR VOTED
REPUBLICAN.
I TWEETED BACK AT HIM.
THAT MEANS -- HE WANTS EVERYONE
TO BE EQUAL, I GUESS.
DEMOCRATIC PRESIDENT, THE HOUSE,
THE SENATE SHOULD BE REPUBLICAN.
I TWEETED BACK, APPARENTLY HE
LIVES IN TEXAS, THAT MEANS HE'S
VOTING FOR BETO, RIGHT?
HE'S JUST PLAYING GAMES.
JUST -- HE'S JUST --
>> THAT WAS VERY SMART ON YOUR
PART, BECAUSE HOW IS THAT
INDEPENDENT?
COMPLETELY INAPPROPRIATE, AND
HOW IS THAT EVEN RESPONSIBLE
WHEN YOU HAVE A PLATFORM LIKE
TWITTER, WHICH IS PERHAPS THE
MOST INFLUENTIAL SOCIAL MEDIA
PLATFORM IN THE WORLD?
>> RIGHT.
WELL, IS IT?
I DON'T KNOW IF IT IS.
HERE'S THE THING.
>> AT LEAST FOR MESSAGING.
>> YEAH.
HE PAID $44 BILLION FOR IT AND
WHY HE CAN DO IT, AND CAN DO
WHATEVER HE WANTS, HE'S BEEN
DOING IT THE PAST COUPLE OF
WEEKS.
DEMANDING MONEY HE'S GOING TO
CHARGE $8 FOR YOUR BLUE CHECK.
HE CAN DO IT BECAUSE HE PAID $44
BILLION.
>> DOES THIS AT ALL MAKE YOU
FEEL LIKE, YOU SEE MOGULS IN
NEWSPAPERS AND NOW ELON BY
TWITTER.
SEEMS ALL DECISIONS HE'S MAKING
ABOUT VERIFICATION, ACCOUNT
SUSPENSION, USING THE PLATFORM
TO WEIGH IN THE WAY WE HAVEN'T
SEEN DONE BEFORE.
MAKING IT UP AS HE GOES BASED ON
HIS OWN EXPERIENCES ON TWITTER?
>> I THINK THAT'S WHAT HE'S
DOING.
CREATING THE TWITTER HE WANTS.
HE WAS AN ACTIVE USER AND KNOWS
THE PRODUCT REALLY WELL.
A LOT OF PEOPLE WHO BUY
COMPANIES DON'T USE THE PRODUCTS
BUT HE'S AFTER AVID, ALMOST
OBSESSIVE, LIKE MYSELF, I MIGHT
SAY, ADDICTIVE USE OF THE
PRODUCT.
SO HE'S DOING WHAT HE WANTS TO
DO.
SO I DON'T KNOW WHAT TO SAY.
HE BOUGHT IT.
NOW IT'S A PRIVATE COMPANY.
NOT A PUBLIC COMPANY.
NO ONE HE'S BEHOLDEN TO, AND
THIS IS WHAT HE DOES.
A LOT OF MEDIA PEOPLE DO THAT.
ALTHOUGH I HAVE TO SAY, RUPERT
MURDOCH WAS CONTROLLED IN
COMPARISON.
>> ASK YOU THIS QUICKLY ON THE
SUBJECT BEFORE WE MOVE ON.
>> SURE.
>> SOMEONE LIKE, YOU KNOW,
CELEBRITY LIKE WHOOPI GOLDBERG
SAYING I'M DONE, UNLESS IT
IMPROVES.
>> YEAH, UH-HUH, YES.
>> IS THAT CONCERNING AT ALL?
DO YOU THINK ELON MUSK CARES
ABOUT THAT?
AND WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> NO.
HE DOESN'T CARE.
HE WAS TOUTING HOW MUCH IT'S UP
NOW.
CREATING CHAOS, AND MIGHT REMIND
YOU OF SOME OTHER PERSON
RECENTLY GOT KICKED OFF THE
PLATFORM.
WHO'S PROBABLY COMING BACK.
HE LOVES CHAOS.
HE'S A CHAOS MONKEY, AS WE SAY
IN SILICON VALLEY.
THAT'S WHAT HE'S DOING.
>> LET ME READ YOU THIS FROM
DONALD TRUMP JR., SOMETHING HE
SAID A FEW DAYS AGO.
"I BELIEVE IF YOU'RE GOING TO BE
A UNITED STATES SENATOR YOU
SHOULD HAVE BASIC COGNITIVE
FUNCTION."
WENT ON TO SAY "IT DOESN'T SEEM
THAT UNREASON BIBLE TO HAVE A,
WOULD GO BRAIN," SAYING "WE'RE
UP AGAINST A DEMOCRATIC WHO DOES
NOT BELIEVE A SENATOR SHOT HAVE
MOOSH FOR A BRAIN" SPEAKING OF
CANDIDATE FOR PENNSYLVANIA
SENATE JOHN FETTERMAN.
I ASK YOU THIS, BECAUSE YOU NOT
ONLY HAD FETTERMAN ON YOUR
PODCAST FOR MORE THAN AN HOUR,
YOU SUFFERED A SIMILAR STROKE,
AND RECOVERED TO SPEAK IN THE
WAY YOU DO TODAY.
SO ANYTHING YOU'D LIKE TO SAY ON
THAT, RESPOND?
ANYTHING YOU'D LIKE TO SAY IN
RESPONSE TO THAT?
>> I REALLY ENJOY DR. DONALD
TRUMP JR., REALLY GREAT.
DR. GOOGLE UNIVERSITY, HE WENT
THERE.
RIDICULOUS.
JUST RIDICULOUS.
THERE'S A DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
SENSORY PROBLEMS.
I HAVE A LOT OF THEM AND TALKED,
I HAD A VERY HARD PROBLEM
SUSTAINING SMALL TALK AND THINGS
LIKE THAT.
SOMETIMES I DID.
SOMETIMES I DIDN'T.
WHEN I INTERVIEWED HIM HE WAS
COGNITIVELY ABLE TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS.
I GOT A LOT OF FLAK FOR SAYING
THAT, BUT HE WAS.
IT WAS A LONG INTERVIEW.
YOU CAN LISTEN TO IT.
WE DIDN'T CHANGE -- A LOT OF UMs
AND AHs, LIKE A LOT OF PEOPLE,
BY THE WAY, AND ABLE TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS.
SUCH A CYNICAL ATTEMPT TO MAKE
SOMEONE LOOK LIKE HE CAN'T THINK
AND HE OBVIOUSLY CAN THINK.
THAT'S NOT THE CASE.
>> KARA, HOPE YOU FEEL BETTER.
THANK YOU FOR GETTING UP FOR US.
>> I NEED A DOCTOR.
AN ACTUAL DOCTOR.
>> A FEW WE CAN SEND.
>> BY THE WAY, I SEE THE
BACK